now it's time for the Ingram angles
unreal real
every once in a while a scientific
journal rears its ugly head to reveal
its ugly bias now we saw this hundreds
of times during covet we're at the
Forefront of that debate and now they're
entering a new Flashpoint gun violence
did you know that black on black crime
is now racist well the Journal of
American Medical of the medical
association AMA thinks that is the case
here's CNN uncritically parroting these
absurd findings mass shootings and major
metropolitan areas in the U.S
disproportionately affect black people
and structural racism may play a role
research at Tulane analyzed data
relating to 51 of the largest
metropolitan areas and found that in
areas with higher black populations mass
shootings are likelier to occur compared
to communities with Higher White
populations
there are also more black people injured
and killed
so instead of identifying the problem in
urban areas as something that requires
attention the black on black crime the
study tries to lay the entire blame
on systemic racism joining me now Larry
Elder conservative radio host Republican
candidate for president Larry
honestly take it away well you know we
just had gay pride month maybe it's time
for a let's take it easy on the white
man month the sad truth is that 60 of
the shootings the robberies the
homicides in America are committed by
black people the sad truth is half of
the homicide victims in America are
black almost all killed by other blacks
as uh same race crime murder is the same
race crime most of the most whites were
killed or killed by other whites
according to the CDC
a young black man a 10 to 43 I'm not
making this up is 13 times more likely
to be murdered than a young white man
and contrary to what Joe Biden said at
Howard University recently they ain't
being killed by white supremacists
they're being killed by other blacks now
unless you're prepared to say black
people are just genetically inclined to
commit more crime you ask you have to
ask yourself what the devil is going on
and what the devil's going on is the ten
thousand pound elephant in the room
which is the epidemic of fatherlessness
seventy percent of black kids enter the
world today without a father in the home
married to the mother 70 up from 25 back
in 1965. 25 of white kids now you know
the white number is going up too and the
stats are clear even Barack Obama once
quoted him if you're raised without a
dead or five times more likely to be
poor and commit crime nine times When
likely to drop out of school in 20 times
Well I could end up in jail and I'm a
single mom and I I'm I'm and this is not
to diss single moms or grandparents are
often raising these kids by themselves
but with the so-called war on poverty
launched by a democrat in the mid 60s
we've incentivized women to marry the
government we've incentivized men to
abandon their financial and more
responsibility and that's it I've been
on radio 30 years and in 30 years I've
tried to get Jesse Jackson on to talk
about these issues he won't come on
Maxine Waters won't come on Al Sharpton
won't come on Minister Farrakhan won't
come on but one of these so-called black
leaders did kawasee and fume who at the
time was president of the NAACP before
that he was in Congress now he's back in
Congress and I said to him Mr emfume as
between the presence of white racism or
the absence of black fathers which poses
a bigger threat to the black community
to his credit without missing a beat he
said the absence of black fathers
I mean that's just that's just the truth
I mean you can't deny that now Larry to
this point there was this new study that
was flagged in reason magazine showing a
stunning link between a decrease in
police presence and stops and an
increase in homicides now look at these
charts you're going to see that during
the pandemic Police Stopped
significantly slowed of course but at
the same time homicides overall surged
and if you look at the specific types
like gun related homicides that also
spiked as did gang-related homicides so
Larry the BLM riots
were responsible for potentially
thousands of deaths I think so it's
called The George Floyd effect or the
BLM effect it's a phenomenon of cops
pulling back from their normal proactive
policing they're by making it less
likely a bad guy is going to be caught
going to be a convicted I'm going to be
incarcerated and there are so-called
excess deaths and these excess deaths
are primarily the black and brown people
living in the inner city that the left
purports to care about but Larry the
NYPD is entering the settlement with the
protest the rioters in New York after
the Floyd killing and it's 13 million
dollars going to I guess what a thousand
people who are arrested right we're
almost almost every time there's one of
these high profile shootings there's a
settlement and the reason for this is to
is to make peace so that people don't
Riot and yell and scream and tear up
things you know we often talk about
Chicago being a violent city when you
look at the per capita homicide rate in
St Louis and in Baltimore it's almost
two times more than that than in Chicago
they're all run by black mayor Chicago's
on his second consecutive black mayor
and we're talking about structural
racism it's insulting and if you
continue to misanalyze the problem the
solutions are going to be forever
illusive we need to all these kids need
mentors and that's one of the reasons
I'm running for president and asking
people to go to my website
larryelder.com give me up there on that
debate stage next month in in Milwaukee
and we're going to talk about this
epidemic and we'd like to see on the
debate and I haven't seen you since La
we're pounding the pavement there
together it was boiling hot Larry of
course it's climate change
as always structural racism
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else